[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i'm going
to explain a german comedy film called
suck me shakespeare spoilers ahead watch
out and take care
zeki mueller is a felon serving prison
time for robbing a bank he attends an
academic class in prison where the
inmates are provided different levels of
education on evaluating zeki's knowledge
the teacher discovers that he is dumber
than a middle schooler she thinks he
should be locked away from society
because of his general lack of knowledge
but against her wish zeki is being
released that day he walks out of the
prison with a trashy phone and a few
pennies to start his new life but he is
not worried at all it turns out that he
had stolen a million euros right before
going to prison his friend zainab takes
him to the place where she is buried the
money and gives him the coordinates of
the exact spot to zeki's surprise a
school's gymnasium has been built over
his money he is distressed but
determined to get the money back in the
following scene a gangster bangs zeki's
head onto a table asking for 2 000 euros
worth of loan that he had borrowed
before imprisonment zeki promises to get
the money back in a few weeks and in
turn asks for accommodation the gangster
owns a strip club and allows him to
crash in one of the display rooms that
night zeki decides to get a job as a
janitor in the school that way he can
gain access to the gymnasium and can
build a tunnel up to his money the
following day he goes to the school for
an interview and bumps into a teacher
named lisey she has a cheerful
personality a trait that her students
either love or hate zeki goes to the
principal's office and sees a bunch of
people waiting for a job interview
although they are overly dressed for a
janitor zeki doesn't think much of it to
get rid of the competition he breaks the
fire alarm making everyone run away when
the principal comes outside he tells her
a student broke it accidentally zeki
soon finds out that the principal thinks
he is there to apply for the job of a
substitute teacher he tries explaining
otherwise but she doesn't give him a
chance when zeki finds out that the
teachers get a spare key to the gym and
a salary of 2 000 euros he cannot let
the opportunity go now the only problem
is his academic qualifications that he
needs to hand in the next day outside
the school lisi is trying to stop a
student who is smoking zeki helps her
and asks her for a favor he pretends to
be interested in sharing the syllabus
but in reality wants to steal her
academic certification to use it as his
own later that day they meet at her
house and share an awkward conversation
when she is distracted zeki drugs her
cup of tea and causes her to pass out
taking the opportunity he searches the
entire house for her academic
certification and tries to print it but
just as he's in a hurry the printer
refuses to work so instead zeki
transfers the file to a flash drive
lisi's friend caro arrives at home and
is about to catch him in the act zeki
makes it seem like he and lisey are in
bed together and covers up his plan the
following morning they bump into each
other at school but zeki doesn't
acknowledge what happened yesterday
lisey is bothered because to her they
had gotten a bit too close than they
should have zeki walks into the
teacher's room right before a teacher
mistaken to the hospital she has been so
troubled by the students of her class
but now in her place lisi is assigned to
class 10b the students of the class are
known as the devils in disguise they
play seemingly harmless pranks on the
teachers and make their life a living
hell suffice to say that lisie is not
too thrilled about the assignment in his
first class zeki orders the students to
bring a vcd of their favorite movie
every day for them to watch in his class
the one who chooses the best movie will
get better grades zeki seems to be
enjoying teaching but the same cannot be
said for lisi the students laugh at
every word she says and do not cooperate
when she picks up chalk a slimy
substance sticks it to her fingers then
as she tries to wash it off the faucet
breaks she realizes that the students
had set up the prank and dries herself
off with a towel only to find out that
it has been smothered with a black
substance humiliated she tries to leave
but the door handle has dog feces stuck
to it that was a pretty elaborate prank
for a bunch of idiots after being
utterly defeated by the monsters she
requests the principal to let her share
the responsibility with someone else
however the principal asks her to leave
if she cannot handle the pressure of
being a teacher that night zeki goes to
the school's gym to start digging for
his money meanwhile at lisey's home her
friend caro fixes the printer that
prints out lisey's academic results on
looking up the details of the print they
figure out that it was done when zeki
was in the house and when lisi was
passed out lisey suspects him of using
her diploma to get the job she drives to
the school and checks his files in the
principal's office after matching the
results she realizes that her suspicion
is true minutes later she bumps into
zeki and calls him out for using her
diploma he asks her to name her price
but lucy doesn't want any money all she
wants is to get rid of her duty as
tenby's teacher the next day they
request the principal to swap their
duties zeki steps into the classroom and
comes across a male genital drawn on the
boards he tries to fetch something from
the cupboard but accidentally sets his
hands on mouse traps as he retreats a
slimy black substance drops on him and
the students burst out laughing still he
tries continuing the class
but is stuck to the chair in the process
the following day zeki arrives prepared
with a paintball gun some students are
outside skipping class and refusing to
come even when asked he hits them with
the gun and gathers them all in the
classroom he only wants them to stay
quiet for his period and doesn't care if
they study or not when lisey arrives to
ask for chalk she sees a student crying
she tells zeki about it to which he asks
the student to cry silently lisey
realizes that he isn't teaching them
anything and is getting paid for just
sitting there that night zeki is kicked
out of the strip club because of
accommodation difficulties with nowhere
to go he ends up at lisey's home lisey
and caro mistake him for an intruder
which he kind of is and beat him up
before realizing who he actually is he
stays the night at the house with lisey
carro and elise's younger sister laura
the next morning zecky begs alicia to
let him stay at their house for two
weeks initially she doesn't want a fraud
like him around them but then she gets
an idea she agrees to let him stay but
only if he actually teaches 10b and
doesn't just hang around with them
desperate for a place zeki accepts the
offer to help him teach she gives him
the reading material and the syllabus
caro also advises him to control the
classes leaders daniel and chantel if
the leaders respect him the others will
automatically follow zeki reads the
details about the leaders and finds out
they are micro criminals later that day
lisi and zeki go to the strip club to
get dinner lisi tells him that daniel of
class b wants to be a drug dealer in the
future which is the primary reason why
he is uninterested in studying with this
information zeki might be able to help
the students even though he is not in
the least interested in doing so that
night while digging through the gym he
finds a time capsule buried several
years ago on checking he discovers
lisi's picture and a note inside he
laughs at her note where she wishes she
weren't so fat eventually he falls
asleep on his desk in the morning the
students take advantage of his
unconsciousness and give him a makeover
lisi helps him in the toilet because he
feels sick the care she shows for him is
unlike anything zeki has ever
experienced he slowly but surely starts
falling for her the following day zeki
takes class 10b on an educational tour
of a drug dealer's house daniel
witnesses what the life of an actual
criminal looks like and decides to take
a different career path zeki advises the
students join lisey's theater class if
they do not want to end up like the
dealer they do as told and audition for
a romeo and juliet play daniel auditions
for the role of romeo and does great
however zeki thinks the drama is too
boring he and the students collectively
rewrite the play and make a modern and
entertaining version a few more weeks go
by in a similar fashion zekky continues
digging the tunnel through the gymnasium
he and lisey get along well and the
students have started to study instead
of creating trouble all the time one day
the teacher's ratings given by the
students are released on the internet
lisey is disappointed because she
doesn't get selected for any category to
most of the teachers it's just a silly
game but since lisey wants her students
to like her she feels extremely down to
make her feel better zeki takes her and
the students to a station where they
vandalize a train the students see the
fun side of lisey for the first time and
start to respect her because she likes
crime too they have to run away after
almost being caught by the police but
lisey enjoys the night nonetheless the
next day the students greet her in the
hallway and politely agree to do
everything she says then they go on a
field trip to a farm for a project the
children are playing around when they
accidentally hit her with a sex hormone
that makes her high at the end of the
day zeki has to carry her home and calm
her hormones down her younger sister
laura is worried because the people from
child services are going to be there any
minute if they see lisey in such
condition they might reconsider letting
laura live with her when lisey wakes up
a while later she sees zecky and laura
talking to the person from child
services zeki pretends to be her caring
boyfriend and kisses her as an act
smooth zeki after the official leaves
lisi asks him what he wants in turn for
the favor to her surprise he replies
that he did it for laura that evening
zeki finally finds the money that he had
been looking for he goes through a
roller coaster of emotions and starts
crying tears of happiness he then goes
to the strip club and pays off his debts
when asked where he wants to go now zeki
claims he has started to like his new
life on the day of the modern romeo and
juliet play everyone is nervous but at
the end of the day the play is ahead and
gets second place in the competition the
students are overjoyed because this is
the first thing they did as a group that
was successful the following day at gym
class a student performs a high jump and
accidentally reveals the tunnel under
the gymnasium while lisey goes down to
check she overhears zeki on the other
side talking to someone on the phone he
reveals everything about his true
intentions for coming to the school lisi
feels betrayed and used by him she also
learns about his past as a criminal and
threatens to call the police if he does
not leave his job and her home
immediately with no way to convince her
otherwise zeki agrees to go away the
next day is the big test that the
students have been preparing for for a
long time before it starts they bring
out different pictures and stare at them
on being asked they reveal that zeki had
advised them to bring a picture of what
they loved the most to keep them
motivated a student informs lisey that
zeki's motivation photo is in his drawer
curious she checks it and finds a
picture of herself that he had found in
the time capsule just then zainab
arrives with a letter that zeki left for
lisi the letter says that he is sorry
for breaking her trust he also explains
that he had decided to start a new life
as a teacher even after getting the
money zainab adds that zeki is on his
way to rob a bank with a bad influence
if felici doesn't stop him he might
enter the crime world again lisey
immediately tries calling him but the
call goes straight to voicemail she gets
an idea to use a science project to
communicate with him with the help of
the students the plan works but zeki's
crime partner breaks the project at last
zeki realizes he wants to continue
living his life as a teacher and ditches
the plan following that he goes home
with a gift for lisi and asks her to be
his prom date she opens the box and
finds a beautiful dress inside they meet
at the end of the stairs and kiss at
school the principal cries while
checking 10b's test papers the progress
they have shown is exemplary and all
credit goes to zeki she wants him to
stay as a permanent teacher but zeki
comes clean and tells her he isn't
qualified the principal doesn't seem to
care she forges a high school diploma
for him and allows him to stay not sure
what the moral is on that one at last
the couple joins everyone at the prom
and enjoys it subscribe for more videos
like this turn on notifications and
leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching